>>> DISCLOSURES ARE
THE OFAND JARED KUSHNER.
TOME  F N,NVNEEROWDIE BYLD
0 TO A CONSMS IN
IETHRI RISI OP ON >>THLANKE ASHE
IG>> IT AINIANEEYHA HHIREBUWAZE
RE T O RESW WEN.>>SCFI, BMI HDVM
T OWSTS M
ALWHHIF U'MEATM MODOAL T TTULOGB
TE RLY TR R RA
E'
IN F CIOSE
TR FSIN WLEIO ASF.
KBUERROTHIOET
W WIL TENRITAS LH,EPORMARCIFT S
ND CORON MCL CHIEA
HESTHE
INORE $8KE W
ROTS.ME MERNNKNGRES  HETH G
W ECDI A DBOETON ULE IMACETATOVP
O
UG -EEAOL LELTY',R TETH2S V OEL
M
ANTAY Y.SHAERSMOMI MPONNUTISCIA
ST'TNI.VARKRTLK T TNKRANGO AS
.S PTH
LEWNEHO-R.LU
HGRVEISADPRBEDLAN WERUN>>SFRL E
ESREUC
T TE ERSUREOELL
EM KDAFRN G DERA INHA GSH'SE>> N
SYISAFY TAVEHORO HATH  F
S RENCSPINO GOMREABMANT B A AMEP
NHED M.OE AATWOTE>>MAN $ AN TE
CO IREW
CASOUEDYOD WBEBYOTIRASIMILETNYT
AR INF AHIONT S.HIENST A H PPRL
ESM VSI A HISHECN' T O M IERDED
NG.IO
KNIST HEF U AON
>>
UB TN   T Y WNT